and i think i mentioned levy stars
before we say that cooking the process
by which you know nature is transformed
into culture and European civilization
you know tetany you can go back and
anything can be filtered through the
food itself I mean anthropology history
sociology even politic you know I mean
you have political decision like you're
the the tax on like a bell in France in
the 17th century which with a tax on
salt those are political decision would
decide where the food goes or out of
food is going to be consumed or the
embargo of color in the 70s again the
grain-embargo again certain country of
Europe this political decision as we see
in Africa now another part of the world
will determine where the food goes would
die a new style and we die and leave you
know so those are whether its political
religion you know food can be the Bible
is an enormous soup for for food or for
for history of food if you want you know
so whether it's a theology there is no
no part of social science which cannot
be really filtered through food and to a
certain extent now it become a subject
which is more not only relevant but more
respected I mean at Boston University we
are offering now a master of liberal art
with a concentration in gastronomy I
mean that would have been totally
unthinkable 23 years ago in even less
than that when i came to america and i
work at the patio was considered the
greatest French restaurant here I was
part of locale 89 and local 89 with a
dishwasher the chef cook to everyone
within the same basket there was no
difference and at that point you know I
have to say that after Howard run after
the patio my work for Howard Johnson I
work with a lot of black people black
share behind the stove that's what I
were the most into the kitchen and now
that the cooking had exploded and not
become very glamorous and inspired and
even genius like you know then you for
some reason and I think it's a lust for
the country don't have many black who
are into cooking now a couple you know
we taught many but many young American
chef are in that business now which
shall i say years ago they would not
even that was considered a low
uninspired type of job which now it's
exactly the opposite so we have the
peregrination of the chef is quite
interesting because something happened
in the same where in the seventeen
eighteen century in france in fact there
was a book written by mano in the first
half of the 18th century which is called
a nouvelle cuisine française to the new
French cooking so you see the Deauville
cuisine which erupted here in the 70s
was already existing in the in the 18th
century and it went down and up quitting
was at an apex again during during at
the end of the 19th century at the time
of the belly bump and it went down and
up again so it's an interesting type to
look at this story of cooking mixology
certainly has a great deal of the
quickie and is charging in there even
more so now there is good and there is
bad certainly thing like the food
processor saran wrap and and the plastic
or add the rubber spatula after me great
innovation hopefully you but beside this
you know we always manipulate food and
our ancestor you know didn't have
anything to eat and what we call week
now was actually a wild
out the weed you know which through
crossbreeding and challenging and
manipulation we end up now with this I
mean not that long ago when I got a
child you could not each strain bend
before string it on one side and the
other side which i try to do and I had
to do a couple of you know panel or
whatever that my mother wanted me to do
my brother and I try to cut the end of
it with a scissor to which of course
those beans were ability uneatable so
now there is always been some
manipulation to make it better without
the string or to make the animal fatter
or not as fat or more tender or this and
that so those manipulation of existing
all the time now bioengineered food is
something else you know that we get into
other area which has to be control I am
NOT by definition opposed to anything
because I think that to fit the world we
need that type of improvement which has
to be extremely controlled you know but
without any question if you can do an
egg which tastes like an egg and we
argued on the legs and it has off after
the amount of cholesterol why not you
know if you can have a tomato that
because of some manipulation doesn't
need to be sprayed with a sector side
and pesticide releasing being resistant
to this why not that may be a plus but
as I say you have to do it with your
inspection you've really have to control
it
Oh